Venezuela despliega la alfombra roja a
turistas comunes
el desembarco de casi 500 visitantes
europeos es tratado como un hecho
histórico
la recepción desde el inicio era
increíble fuimos recibido con música con
danza nunca vi algo
en la marea es el primer crucero en
atacar en Venezuela en 15 años el crimen
desenfrenado la hiperinflación y los
servicios básicos poco confiables como
el agua y la electricidad ha mantenido a
raya a los extranjeros durante mucho
tiempo varios gobiernos todavía
desaconsejan viajar allí los
funcionarios locales están ansiosos por
celebrar esta ocasión
Bueno hoy es un día de alegría para
todos los neopartanos nos beneficiamos y
se beneficiarán varias varios rubros de
la economía del estado y es bueno es un
comienzo de la llegada de varios
cruceros que van a empezar a venir
Venezuela ha estado en crisis durante
más de una década ya que años de mala
gestión económica y corrupción
contribuyeron a la hiperinflación y la
grave escasez de bienes básicos más de 7
millones de personas han oído del país
desde 2015 según la ONU la economía y el
sector del turismo han mostrado
recientemente pequeños signos de
recuperación especialmente después de
que los rusos comenzaran a llegar tras
la invasión a Ucrania
el líder venezolano Nicolás Maduro que
ha apoyado a Vladimir Putin en medio de
la guerra también dice que está listo
para normalizar las relaciones con
Estados Unidos